one of the striking things about this
piece of equipment is that the last
thing that you'd expect it to do is work
oh but it does time it really does and
to prove it we've come to the birthplace
of this board Montreal Canada to capture
the action for ourselves and meet the
ambitious aviator Alexandre
tonight is amazing feeling sometimes you
might be dreaming I would like to see
how feel how this will fly and they have
it it's it's here you can actually
experience it it becomes somehow an
extension of your feet it's just like
your feet are able to push through air
so how is this fantastic flying machine
put together Alexander's hoverboard
design is simple but beautiful it's six
and a half feet long or two meters and
it has eight rotors arranged in a
spider-like fashion
Alexandre stands at the center and flies
up into the sky Alexandre controls the
power that goes to the rotors by using
the throttle that he holds in his hand
so it's very responsive very powerful a
little bit dangerous so the controller
is for power but how does he steer
steering and balance do not come from
any controller he has to use his feet
and his body Alexandre creates forward
thrust by shifting his body weight
forward
thus orienting all the rotors slightly
backwards now they're giving him upward
thrust but they're also giving him a
little bit of forward thrust
alex has to have amazing skills to pilot
this board because most of the weight is
Alex himself the whole system is
extremely top-heavy
Alexandra at all times must keep his
center of mass directly above the hover
board that way he won't tilt forward or
backward too much and come crashing down
I was confident from the start but this
is in terms of technological challenge
this one is not totally safe but it's
gonna be safe at some point eventually
you